[Music]
many people would say this becomes the
most anticipated halftime show i hope so
how in the heck are you going to make it
all work our guy's got a lot of hit
records and he's going to perform them
[Music]
all
[Music]
at the end of the day he's the one that
has to stand there for a little over 13
minutes
and dazzle 120 million people as the
weekend steps onto the world's biggest
stage
how will halftime adapt during the
pandemic well
jesse says his team is taking the show
out of the box
we're gonna use the stadium to present
the show in a way that has never been
presented before
but it is absolutely a live live
halftime show
inside that stadium in more places than
you would expect
the production team for the pepsi super
bowl halftime show which airs on cbs
will be inside the stadium jesse the
show's first black executive producer
is also in charge of this year's grammy
and oscar shows
he says safety is a priority expect mass
and shields i look like a storm trooper
with my shield and everything
will you guys live in a little bubble
down at the super bowl will you go into
like a bubble yeah we're all like
you know you don't want to be the one
right that like
you know you went out to wherever
and then now you're like stuck outside
and that'll be it yeah
no yeah it'll just be you waving from
the fence the fence
in orlando also inside the bubble
[Music]
yep miley's heading to the super bowl
the 28 year old will perform at the
first ever tick-tock tailgate
for 7 500 vaccinated health care workers
sorry for crashing your meeting nfl
commissioner roger goodell
invited them on a surprise zoom i wanted
to tell you that we want
your team to be there oh my gosh
the big day is just 13 days away and it
will be a major milestone for donnie
wahlberg
when the new kids performed at the super
bowl half time
back in 30 years ago this year 30 years
ago
this year 30 years right
we did it with disney which at the time
you know i was trying to be a tough
young man i was like why are we doing
this disney thing
well the fans they can expect a lot but
it was actually
you know quite an honor and to look back
now and see what halftime has become
in the super bowl to know that we were
the first sort of
pop group to do that and to be part of
that it's a pretty cool one
you